welcome back we are now on problem
number 12 which i will do in magenta
12. all right if 2x
is less than y
which is less than zero huh so both of
these are negative and 2x is more
negative all right which of the
following is greatest so they give us a
bunch of choices
so see choice a
choice a is
minus 2x
choice b
is
minus
2x
plus y
choice c
is the 2x
choice d
is 0
and choice e
is minus y
okay
so the interesting thing that should
immediately jump out at you is that both
2x and y are negative right because
they're all less than 0 and 2x is even
more negative than y right if i were to
draw a number line
if if this is a number line
it might be instructive to even show it
let's see number line
and
this is 0
this is
y
2x would be some place over here we
don't know exactly where i mean you know
this could be
0 this could be
i don't know i could pick random numbers
this could be negative 1
negative 1 and then this could be i
don't know this could be
negative 2 right these are just random
numbers and actually that might be the
the best way of of of doing this problem
i mean we could reason through it and
actually i will but the easiest thing is
well let me just take these numbers that
satisfy this inequality and see what
happens with them right and that
probably is the fastest way so in our
case what's minus 2x
so if 2x is minus 2 that would be minus
times minus 2 right because 2x is minus
2.
so that equals plus 2.
what's 2x plus y
so 2x is minus 2. plus y is minus 1 so
it becomes minus 3 so this becomes minus
minus 2
minus
1.
so
there's minus 3 but then you have a
minus outside this plus
so we can immediately say that this this
is not the greatest right because we
already found one that is greater
two x would be
it two x is just minus two
right we said that two x is minus two
zero is 0
minus y in our example would be 1. in
all of these situations
this is the largest and you could try it
with any set of numbers that satisfy
this i mean we could have we could have
called instead of saying this is 2x we
could call this z and done it
but and and without doing the number
line and without kind of picking numbers
you could have also reasoned you could
have said you know 2x is more negative
than
y so if you put a negative in front of
2x it's going to be more positive right
because a negative times a negative is a
positive so it'll become a more positive
so
first of all this number will be a
negative number so that's not right this
number will be positive so 0 can't be
the answer and then you say well what's
bigger minus y or minus 2x well minus 2x
is more negative
so my or i'm sorry 2x is more negative
so minus 2x will be more positive so you
know it's not going to be this you then
you're picked between these two
and then you have to say well what's
more negative 2x
2x or 2x plus y
well 2x plus y is going to be a more
negative number because you know both of
these are negative numbers when you add
them you're going to get something even
more negative than either of them then
we take the negative of that you get a
larger positive number that last
explanation might have been confusing
and really the easiest way is just pick
some numbers that satisfy this
inequality and then
pick and then substitute and then you
have your answer all right number 13
which i'll do in this pale yellow
13. carlos delivered n packages on
monday so monday
n
four times as many packages on tuesday
as on monday so on tuesday he did four
times as many so that's four and
and three more and not not three times
three more packages on wednesday than
monday
so wednesday
three more packages on wednesday than
monday so this is n plus three three
more than on
monday what is the average
number of packages he delivered per day
over the three days so that what's the
average of these three numbers so see we
sum them up
n
plus four n
plus n plus three and we divide by three
and there's three days
see n plus four is five n
plus three is six n so it's six n plus
three over three divide all the terms by
three that equals 2 n
plus 1 and we are done
that was number 13 which was c
choice c
okay
number 14.
number 14.
if this looks exciting
if a
a plus
b
a plus b to the one half
is equal to
a
minus b
to the minus
one half
which of the following must be true and
they say you know
b is equal to zero
that's choice a they say a plus b
is equal to one a minus b is equal to
one
a squared plus b squared is equal to one
a squared minus b squared is equal to
one
well what i want to do is i just want to
write this in a in kind of a form that
that makes more sense to me so this is
you know this is essentially saying the
square root
of a plus b
is equal to
1 over the square root
of
a
minus b
right
negative
one-half so let's multiply both sides of
this equation times the square root of a
minus b
the square root of a minus b this side
will just cancel out right
you're just left with one this is the
same thing as the square root
of a
minus b
times a plus
b right
and then on the right hand side we're
just left with a one
and what's a minus b times a plus b
right that's so this is the square root
of a squared minus b squared is equal to
1.
and then what do we know if if we could
well we could square both sides right so
if we if we square both sides so we take
both to the second power
what are we left with
that this radical sign goes away so
we're left with a squared minus b
squared is equal to one
and that is choice e
let's see do i have time to do
the next problem looks complicated so
let me wait for to do the next problem
in the next video see you soon